we're here with the official dark side
character breakdown for injustice - now
this one's taken from nether realms
livestream but the game launches just
two weeks from now on May 16th so be
sure to LIKE and subscribe to keep up
with all of our injustice - coverage
right but if you want an absolute
powerful brute who just overwhelms
opponents play dark side absolutely he
is basically the feel of a boss
character but balanced to be a player
character oh did you oh I'm gonna do
okay all right so let's talk about he
does yeah he um he's the master of the
Omega beans which are extremely powerful
eye lasers I've heard that about
'mentally and they never missed they can
zigzag around they'll catch the opponent
and you can do it obviously in the air
round anyway anywhere else you can do it
a lot of places do it up load you up you
can do it down you can do down you can
do straight you can straight in a lot of
different options for violent and they
are high damaging they have very fast
recovery they take up the whole screen
and they're very very very fast now they
are high the straight one right so the
opponent can Doug it but they don't have
a lot of time to advance even when they
duck it they are very very good
projectile moves now it's Peter Byrne
you're in actually control it's wrecked
we're going to direct it so you could do
this straight one and hold down and I
leaned down yep
oh man my bad huh there we go sorry
alright alright so or you can do the
entire ant do the anti-air one oh and
you can aim down if you do it yes there
you go
so you're almost kind of like drawing
that hour you are yeah that's really
cool um alright so he's got the Omega
beams but what else does yeah well he
also has his palm strike which is a
great combo ender and he can be to burn
that for additional damage and that's
kind of one of the main moves you can
use to push the opponent away or to end
your java combo a lot of his stuff when
we burn pushes him away right back into
his game exactly where he wants to be he
also has his knee bash which is another
good combo ender and this is one of his
good wakeup attacks is invincible yeah
Tyler uses an allow Lika yeah the meter
burned version makes him safe so you can
use that as a safe wakeup attack and
kicks him away and then it kicks him
away then he goes back to shooting Omega
bees I do I always do um and then he's
got the stomp right yes sir he has he
has some ability options he has a
teleport and he will teleport next to
the opponent damn battery yeah it was
and he can do that on the ground or on
the air now the really cool thing about
the air teleport is he can actually
attack right out of it as he's landing
he can go to any with jump attacks so
it's a very good strategy if the
opponent is ducking we're trying to jump
in and they're trying to get past the
beams you can all of a sudden get right
next to them and then start attacking
you can teleport and throw or teleport
and sweep right through
and then he has his ear stock which is
actually a jumping low special mood so
even though it's an air attack it's not
an overhead it's a low they have to
block low and you can again do it
straight out of his teleport so you have
a ready-made mix-up of teleport and you
a jump attack or teleport in the air
stomp
and that's while the opponent is trying
to deal with the Omega P being a little
dirty either so it's a very simple
straightforward tactic that's always
going to be effective right Tyler you
picked up Darkseid
I have I really like Darkseid there's he
has a couple really that we can be done
as specials I think those Oh his
character well right now his character
power is he summons parodies and he has
two three different pair of demons he
can summon he can summon explodey guy
and he'll sit there and chill out and
then when Darkseid is ready you do the
character power about button again and
you'll explode and that pops up and you
can do a beam or combo it's loading at
explodey got down and it has a really
cool function where if exploding guys
out if you were throw go up throw
exploding guy explodes and darks I can
get a combo you can get a free back
three so all of us you know throws are
normally low damaging options to open up
the opponent no one really gets killed
by only throws but when exploding guys
out his throat becomes a combo starter
for some people yeah he he also has uh
he's mister one just character bites
karen proper itself is a flying
parademon and from here he has a couple
options he can shoulder ram you and he
can spit a fireball and now darkside is
free to move around wallace pair of
demons are out so the idea would be you
put out the parademon and then you can
shoot your beams or you can teleport it
and any time you can release the
fireball but if Darkseid's hit the pair
of demons will unfortunately get they'll
get two more lives and they'll leave
their master back apocalypse yes back to
they go back to a boom tube back to
apocalypse absolutely and then finally
back in character power is charging guy
and you'll actually go into a little
boom tube
and come out as it over and that's an
instant overhead is that the sound that
is the sound even a feeling great all
right you're gonna steam again okay
we were worried about Chevy right with
impressions all right um so super moon
oh this is a great one so let's just
miss it first I did have some now that's
Newsies so one of the fun things about
the trailer was the super moon and
there's a lot of speculation on the
internet about how it works how does the
actual view works and the trick is you
control it yes as soon as you do it
Tyler actually gets to control the drain
draw something fun this I can't draw
okay will do okay you're not let me try
let me try
so you can go up you can go down you can
go back you can completely circle around
as long as it's active you have free
control of movement so there is no
escape
it's the ultimate zoning tool yeah now
that's pretty Clary gosh that was crazy
bye miss yeah the better right yeah you
can do crazy stuff but it's really cool
yeah he also has a really a lot of
really cool strings news dinner he does
and his strings use the Omega beams even
his normal attacks so you can kind of
show some my favorite is obviously I
like doing the overhead slap this one
here I'll make
right you can also do things like this
entire that you wouldn't be the master
of a mega beans if he brought you some
on his play style has Omega beans so I
would say the key ones are uh back light
attack is a very quick overhead he does
not have a low launcher but he does have
some pretty decent loads to compliment
like his low laser or a sweep he also
has four to three which is a ford
advancing mid attack that leads to a
combo you did and then he has your
typical jabs like one one two which ends
in the power blast or one to one plus
three which is going to throw I really
like it can switch stances yeah good
position right that yeah his basic
attacks are they're pretty much as blue
power in the DeMeo beams he's he's not
really an up-close-and-personal brawler
he he is meant to be played from a
distance and when he gets in he does a
lot of damage and he pushes you out and
he goes back to playing his mega mean
one thing I really like to is this back
this one here they overhead this as
you've seen can be meter burn at this
point and then that's your main combo do
a combo yeah right so yeah so that's
really like that that's been on the
basic dark side yes I'd use hopelessly
dark side a little bit later too
so oh yeah and I know you've had a lot
of a lot of fun playing peas you feel
powerful playing dark so you really do
and if you have every game I there's
always these characters I don't think
will be my favorite characters and I
started playing dark side like yeah yeah
that's my guy alright let's go real
quickly you want to go through some of
his uh alright his other we made two
other load outs for him
oh I can't wait to show you here I
always do that he always does that no
we're gonna see the other one now well
that's what you know that's fun
okay so he does can't keep him down
alright so the first one we gave is hate
slam which normally you have two two one
plus three and this is mostly a combo
ender you do
but you can actually beat a burner to do
even more damage you can start combos
with it or like I said you can extend
your compliments so it basically just
turns one of his better combos into an
even better composter look at that year
- it's all gold legally need and then we
gave him instead of his anti-air beam he
gets reverse beams he will actually turn
on kind of hit you from box so you think
it goes all the way around the earth and
then comes back I feel like you go
through a boom tube directly off screen
for another boob to the other side but I
feel like we would hear the boom tube
well I mean he may have silent stuff
though no there's no silent boom to get
you're being ridiculous
because it's got a minute's name shall
be loud back exactly all right if that's
Steve's four minutes so if you're
playing a matchup where you're really
controlling the ground and you don't
need to worry about the air as you feel
you don't need the anti-air one and you
want even more ground control boom here
you go - ah Derek knock into a compass
it can't look at that alright that's
pretty sneaky sneak all right so that's
one load out and then we went for a high
mobility load out this would be a load
out if you really want to beat play
keep-away you don't want to be up close
at all so this gives you a way teleport
normally his teleport instantly put you
right next to the opponent but in this
loadout we gave him the ability to
teleport away dip out because that's
where he wants to be because that's
where he wants to we're showing them
some secret looks at Green Arrow's
costumes for that's true you get a
notice that you don't care and you can
do this in the air
all right and just like normally you can
attack out of it so this will keep the
opponent guessing they don't know if
you're going to teleport in and they
don't know if you're gonna teleport back
so you use the back of like mobility
yeah you can actually make darkside even
warm but character who's normally the
teleport is is real big mobility option
you can really make them a high mobility
character so that's our quick look at
dark that's our quick look at darkside
let's switch characters just to go back
to arrow we had already shown some of
the cool I'll does kind of ruin that's
do you want to control them now you got
it